sudden and surprise announcements in the
world of cable news Tucker Carlson one
of the most prominent right-wing voices
in the country he is out at Fox News
despite the largest audience of any host
at that Network and then a few clicks
away over at CNN longtime anchor Don
Lemon abruptly fired after 17 years most
recently as co-host of their new Morning
Show lemon said he was stunned by the
decision to let him go saying that his
agent told him he was terminated Monday
morning without management speaking to
him CNN disputes this saying a meeting
was offered but there's even more shock
rather over the termination of Tucker
Carlson who at one point commanded one
of the largest audiences in cable news
history